[Laughter]
today's episode we're gonna talk about
the office specifically our top three
favorite Dwight and Jim moments people
often say that Ryan and I have kind of a
Dwight and Jim vibe I think Jordan and I
have a Dwight and Jim vibe you're the
Jim and your head right I'm the Jim
right do your best Jim face pretty good
okay Jim face Bryan's is bad
what do you mean mine was bad do it
let's play the clip 78 280z I've bought
it for 1,200 fixed strips now what 3
grand is His Prophet
yeah new engine suspension I got Rhys
brackets and photos hold on hold on
judges in session what is the problem
here
put my stuff in jello again that's real
professional
thanks the third time it wasn't funny
the first times I it's ok here but
people sometimes take advantage because
it's so relaxed I'm a volunteer
sheriff's deputy on the weekends and you
cannot screw around there it's sort of
one of the roles that it's my staple no
no no do not take it out if to eat it
out of there because they're starving
people in the world and which I hate and
it is a waste of that kind okay you know
what you can be a witness can you
reprimand him please
how do you know it was me it's always
you are you gonna discipline him or not
ooh discipline kinky all right here's
the deal you guys thing about a
practical joke is that you have to know
when to start as well as when to stop
yeah and yeah Jim now is the time to
stop putting Dwight's personal effects
into jello okay threat I'm sorry because
I've always been your biggest flan you
guys ever done an epic prank like that
it's hard to top that one but I feel
like I might be able to do that wait
what's that I think it's oh my god
Jillian what's going on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all your vape pen is in the jello we got
to eat it out get to eat it no kidding
no we're not burnt out you have to one
is mine and the one that one that's not
the custard is now officially you call
jello custard anyway good luck because
I'm Jim that looks like you are you did
you make that Jillian this was very
funny this was very funny I never do
something behind my back again good
joins actually excited cuz now he gets
to eat his way into his game
no can you do that not like sexual
harass we're gonna get flags okay well
while Jordan eats that I've got a
question for you guys I was browsing
rennet and I was in the data is
beautiful subreddit and a user named
split soul actually calculated who had
the most lines on the office so between
Jim and Dwight who do you think had more
lines over the nine seasons Dwight
Dwight vote for Dwight vote for Dwight
Wow I thought you guys would go for Jim
you're correct Michael of course ed the
most with over the nine seasons ten
thousand nine hundred and seventy three
which is especially impressive because
he wasn't in it the last couple Twite
then just edges Jim out with six
thousand nine hundred and three and then
Jim's in third place with 6330 Jillian
throw up that next clip hey hey who are
you
faxing so early in the morning oh I know
explain I don't have a ton of contact
with this Granton branch but before I
left I took a box of Dwight's stationery
so from time to time I send why faxes
from himself
from the future Dwight at 8 a.m. today
someone poisons to coffee do not drink
the coffee more instructions will follow
cordially future Dwight don't thank me
later
Hannah you picked that one you send a
lot of faxes you know what I have been
sending faxes into New York because
everything's so old school here
and again Department you have to say
eight faxes and a piece of your blood
real estate people like love fax
machinery fax machine machine technology
but then refused to like adopt venmo or
anything else that you know either those
it's crackling sounds wrong I think it's
really clogged up with jell-o I think
the plastic wrap was breached and
there's jell-o in the good no you'll
thank me later morning Dwight who are
you
Who am I I'm Jim we've been working
together for 12 years we're jug Dwight
you're not Jim Jim's not Asian you
seriously never noticed
hey hats off to you for not seeing race
all right then Jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
Wellington systems sold them ten cases
of 24-pound liter stock or were you
talking about Krieger Murphy because I
didn't close that one yet but I'm hoping
I've got a voicemail from Paul Krieger
waiting for me please enter your
password
you have one new message
no no no no that is sensitive
information only for employees not
Outsiders why cut it out I'm trying to
work you don't work here you're not Jim
Jim I got us that dinner reservation
Grieco 7:30 oh great can't wait
Jim's at the dentist this morning and
Steve is an actor friend of ours I don't
know who you are but you were not Jim
this is Jim he's like gaslighting him
and makes him question his sanity that
one comes to us from season 9 so we've
got all the way from season 1 to the end
season 9 mmm
they kept it up you picked that one
Jordan have you ever done an epic prank
like that I gave everyone in the cast
here cupcakes seemingly as a gesture of
like just goodwill but I made them think
that it was poison a little bit and you
kind of did poison them with your like
gestures of
obscenities I did air-hump all of the
cupcakes any good you know from when
when I put your vape pen in jello tastes
like starburst tastes like it tasted
good I don't know if it's a prank in
college I got in trouble for being drunk
in the in the dorm as one does someone
she builds a building advisor and I had
showered and and put on my pajamas a
knock on the door and they and I answer
the door like yes who are you who am i
and they're like we hear your roommates
been very drunk pretty passive
aggressive towards me but she was like a
very good student and I was like you're
absolutely correct no okay well we need
her idea
write her up and I was like she was so
black out she lost everything I can't
keep your ID I'm like I put her on her
side she's fine
and so they're like no we need to make
sure she's okay I'm like come on in so
they came Advisor goes like this to make
sure she's breathing and she's just like
sound asleep and they look at your
horrible voice I was like I was never
gonna give you her ID and my roommate
never woke up he's got a shout out for
us Ana yesterday we had the hundred
dollar challenge for $7.00 grilled
cheese challenge nemesis breaks said
pile of cash I can always get the best
grilled cheese in the world at my mom's
house from which I live in the basement
so the hundred dollar pile of cash would
help support my cause and buying more
video games to further my stay in the
basement and I appreciate how honest
this youtuber was so thank you now
missus brakes I'm glad we have the same
life goals I love the phrase from which
I live in the base you can actually see
full episodes of the office every week
on comedy central please like comment
and subscribe see you next time
[Music]